Hello, this is Joel Blackstock, and you're listening to the Taproot Therapy Collective Podcast. Today we're going to be doing a review, but I try and write all of the book reviews in a way that makes it not necessary for you to read the book, because I know that most people are not going to read any of these books. You can and should. There's some interesting things in a lot of the books that we review, but I try and do the book reviews in a way that gives you the context to understand the book, and then also help you translate some of the, in some cases, antiquated language, in other cases,
你好，我是乔尔·布莱克斯托克（Joel Blackstock），你正在收听的是“主根疗法集体”（Taproot Therapy Collective）播客。今天我们要进行一次书评，但我尽量以一种让你无需阅读原书的方式来撰写所有书评，因为我知道大多数人并不会去读这些书。你当然可以读，也应该读。我们评述的许多书中都有一些有趣的内容，但我尝试通过书评为你提供理解该书的背景，并帮助你将其中一些在某些情况下显得过时，或者在另一些情况下过于学术化、脱离实际的文字，转化为普通人能够理解并运用的常识。
just highly academic or kind of out of touch writing into a normal concept that a normal person could pick up and use. So the book that I have written a review of today is called Lament of the Dead, Psychology After Carl Jung's The Red Book. And it is a conversation between James Hillman and Sanu Samshadani, and the book is presented like a dialogue. Before I jump into that review, I want to read two quotes. One is from the first page of the book, and the other one is from Carl Jung's The Red Book, of which The Lament for the Dead book that I'm reviewing is a discussion of.
今天我所评述的书名为《死者的哀歌：卡尔·荣格〈红书〉之后的心理学》（Lament of the Dead, Psychology After Carl Jung's The Red Book）。这是一本由詹姆斯·希尔曼（James Hillman）和索努·沙姆达萨尼（Sonu Shamdasani）共同完成的对话录，全书以对话形式呈现。在进入书评之前，我想先读两段引文。一段来自该书的第一页，另一段来自卡尔·荣格的《红书》，而我所评述的《死者的哀歌》正是对《红书》的探讨。
So this is from The Red Book by Carl Jung. The years of which I have spoken to you when I pursued the inner images were the most important time of my life. Everything else is to be derived from this. It began at that time, and the later details hardly matter anymore. My entire life consisted in elaborating what had burst forth from the unconscious and flooded me like an enigmatic stream and threatened to break me. That was the stuff and the material for more than only one life. Everything later was merely the outer classification, the scientific elaboration, and the integration into life. But the numinous beginning, which contained everything, was then.
这段话摘自卡尔·荣格的《红书》：“我曾对你们说过，我追求内在意象的那些年是我一生中最重要的时光。其他一切都源于此。它始于那时，后来的细节已不再重要。我的一生都在阐述那些从无意识中喷涌而出、像神秘溪流般淹没我并威胁要摧毁我的东西。那是不仅属于一个生命，而是属于更多生命的素材。后来的一切都仅仅是外部的分类、科学的阐述以及对生活的整合。但那个包含了一切的、神圣的开端，就在那时。”
Carl Jung, preface for the Red Book. And this next quote is the first page of Lament of the Dead. James Hillman. I was reading about this practice that the ancient Egyptians had of opening the mouth of the dead. It was a ritual, and I think that we don't do that with our hands, but opening the Red Book seems to be opening the mouth of the dead. It was a ritual, and I think that we don't do that with our hands, but opening the Red Book seems to be opening the mouth of the dead. Sanu Shamsadani. It takes blood. That's what it takes. The work is Jung's Book of the Dead, his descent into the underworld in which there was an attempt to find the way of relating to the dead. And he comes to the realization that unless we come to terms with the dead, we simply cannot live,
卡尔·荣格，《红书》序言。接下来这段引文来自《死者的哀歌》第一页。詹姆斯·希尔曼：“我读到过古埃及人有一种为死者‘开口’的仪式。那是一种仪式，我想我们虽然不用双手去做这件事，但打开《红书》似乎就是在为死者开口。”索努·沙姆达萨尼：“这需要付出鲜血。这就是代价。这部作品是荣格的《亡灵书》，是他进入冥界的旅程，他在其中试图寻找与死者建立联系的方式。他意识到，除非我们与死者达成和解，否则我们根本无法生活，
and that our life is dependent on finding answers to their unanswered questions. Lament for the Dead, page 1. And so with that, I'll begin the review now. Begun in 1914, Swiss psychologist Carl Jung's The Red Book lay dormant for almost 100 years before its eventual publication. Opinions are divided on whether Jung would have published the book if he had lived longer. He did send drafts of it to publishers in early life, but he seemed in no hurry to publish the book despite his advancing age. Regardless, it was of enormous importance to the psychologist, being shown to only a few confidants and family members. More importantly, the process of writing the Red Book was one of the most formative periods of Jung's life.
我们的生活依赖于为他们未解的问题找到答案。”《死者的哀歌》，第1页。那么，现在我开始书评。瑞士心理学家卡尔·荣格于1914年开始撰写的《红书》，在最终出版前沉寂了近100年。关于荣格如果多活几年是否会出版这本书，人们意见不一。他在早年确实曾将草稿寄给出版商，但尽管年事已高，他似乎并不急于出版。无论如何，这对这位心理学家来说意义重大，他只将其展示给少数知己和家人。更重要的是，撰写《红书》的过程是荣格一生中最具塑造性的时期之一。
In the time that Jung worked on the book, he came into direct experience with the forces of the deep mind and the collective unconscious. For the remainder of his career, he would use the experience to build concepts and theories about the unconscious and the repressed parts of the human mind. In the broadest sense, Jungian psychology has two goals. One, integrate and understand the deepest and most repressed parts of the human mind, and two, don't let them eat you alive in the process. Jungian psychology is about excavating the most repressed parts of self that Jung called the shadow, and learning to hold them so that we can know exactly who and what we are.
在荣格创作这本书的时期，他直接体验到了深层心灵和集体无意识的力量。在余下的职业生涯中，他利用这些经验构建了关于无意识和人类心灵被压抑部分的观念与理论。从最广泛的意义上讲，荣格心理学有两个目标：第一，整合并理解人类心灵中最深层、最被压抑的部分；第二，在这个过程中不要让它们把你活活吞噬。荣格心理学旨在挖掘荣格所称的“阴影”——即自我中最被压抑的部分，并学会掌控它们，以便我们能确切地知道自己是谁、是什么。
Jung called this process individuation. Jungian psychology is not, and should not be understood as an attempt to create a religion. It was an attempt to build a psychological container for the forces of the unconscious. While not a religion, it served a similar function as religion. Jungian psychology serves as both a protective buffer and a lens to understand and clarify the self. It helps us grow, and it helps us contain the things that we are not yet ready to hold. Jung described his psychology as a bridge to religion. His hope was that it could help psychology understand the function
荣格称这一过程为“个体化”。荣格心理学不是，也不应被理解为一种试图创造宗教的尝试。它是试图为无意识的力量构建一个心理容器。虽然它不是宗教，但它发挥了与宗教类似的功能。荣格心理学既是保护性的缓冲，也是理解和澄清自我的透镜。它帮助我们成长，并帮助我们容纳那些我们尚未准备好面对的事物。荣格将他的心理学描述为通往宗教的桥梁。他的希望是，它能帮助心理学理解人类对宗教、神话和超验性的需求功能。
of the human need for religion, mythology, and the transcendental. Jung hoped that his psychology could make religion occupy a healthier and more mindful place in our culture by making the function of religion within humanity more conscious. Jung did not dislike religion. He viewed it as problematic when the symbols of religion became concretized and people took them literally. Jungian psychology itself has roots in Hindu religious traditions. Jung often recommended that patients of lapsed faith return to their religious traditions of origin in order to reclaim them by understanding them as metaphor. He has case studies encouraging patients to resume Christian or Muslim religious practices as a source of healing and integration. Jung did have a caveat though. He recommended that patients return to their traditions with
荣格希望他的心理学能通过使宗教在人类中的功能变得更加自觉，从而让宗教在我们的文化中占据一个更健康、更理性的位置。荣格并不反感宗教。他认为当宗教符号被具体化、人们对其进行字面解读时，问题就出现了。荣格心理学本身植根于印度教的宗教传统。荣格经常建议那些失去信仰的病人回归他们最初的宗教传统，通过将其理解为隐喻来重新获得它们。他有许多案例研究，鼓励病人恢复基督教或穆斯林的宗教实践，作为治愈和整合的源泉。不过，荣格有一个告诫。他建议病人带着
an open mind. Instead of viewing the religious traditions as prescriptive lists of rules or literal truths, he asked patients to view them as metaphors for self-discovery and processes for introspection. Jung saw no reason to make religious patients question their faith. He did see the need for patients who had abandoned religion to re-examine its purpose and function. The process of writing the Red Book was itself a religious experience for Jung. He realized after his falling out from Freud that his own religious tradition and the available psychological framework of the time was not enough to help contain the raw and weathering forces of his own unconscious that were assailing him then. Some scholars believe
开放的心态回归传统。他要求病人不要将宗教传统视为规定性的规则清单或字面真理，而是将其视为自我发现的隐喻和内省的过程。荣格认为没有理由让有宗教信仰的病人质疑他们的信仰。但他确实认为，那些已经放弃宗教的病人需要重新审视其目的和功能。撰写《红书》的过程对荣格本人来说就是一种宗教体验。在与弗洛伊德决裂后，他意识到自己所属的宗教传统和当时现有的心理学框架，不足以帮助他容纳当时正侵袭他的、原始且狂暴的无意识力量。一些学者认为，
that Jung was partially psychotic while writing the Red Book, and others claim that he was in a state of partial dissociation, or simply use Jung's term of active imagination. The psychotic is drowning while the artist is swimming. The waters that both inhabit, however, are the same. Written in a similar voice to the King James Bible, the Red Book has a religious and transcendental tone. It is written on vellum, in heavy calligraphy,
荣格在撰写《红书》时处于部分精神病状态，而另一些人则声称他处于部分解离状态，或者仅仅使用了荣格所说的“主动想象”这一术语。精神病患者在溺水，而艺术家在游泳。然而，他们所处的却是同一片水域。以类似于《钦定版圣经》的语调写成，《红书》具有一种宗教和超验的基调。它写在牛皮纸上，用厚重的书法书写，
with gorgeous hand-illuminated script, and Jung took inspiration for mystical and alchemical texts when he made its full-page illustrations. It is easier to define the Red Book by what it is not than by what it is. According to Jung, it is not a work of art. It is not a scholarly psychological endeavor. It is also not an attempt to create a religion. It was an attempt for Jung to heal himself in a time of pain and save himself from a madness by giving voice to the forces underneath his partial psychotic episode. The Red Book was a kind of container to help Jung witness the forces of the deep unconscious, in the same way that religion and Jungian psychology are containers
配有华丽的手绘插图，荣格在绘制全页插图时从神秘和炼金术文本中汲取了灵感。定义《红书》是什么，不如定义它不是什么更容易。根据荣格的说法，它不是一件艺术品。它不是一项学术性的心理学研究。它也不是试图创造一种宗教。对荣格而言，这是他在痛苦时期治愈自己、通过为他部分精神病发作之下的力量赋予声音来拯救自己的一种尝试。《红书》是一种容器，帮助荣格见证深层无意识的力量，就像宗教和荣格心理学是
for the ancient unconscious forces in the vast ocean under the human psyche. Lament of the Dead, Psychology After Carl Jung's The Red Book is a dialogue between ex-Jungian analyst James Hillman and Jungian scholar Sanu Shamdasani about the implications that The Red Book has for Jungian psychology and psychology at large. Like the Red Book, it was controversial when it was released. James Hillman was an early protege of Jung, who later became a loud critic of parts of Jung's psychology. Hillman wanted to create an archetypal psychology that would allow patients to directly experience and not merely analyze the psyche.
人类心灵深处广阔海洋中原始无意识力量的容器一样。《死者的哀歌：卡尔·荣格〈红书〉之后的心理学》是前荣格派分析师詹姆斯·希尔曼与荣格学者索努·沙姆达萨尼之间的一场对话，探讨了《红书》对荣格心理学乃至整个心理学的意义。像《红书》一样，它在发布时也引起了争议。詹姆斯·希尔曼是荣格早期的门徒，后来成为荣格心理学部分内容的激烈批评者。希尔曼想要创造一种原型心理学，让病人能够直接体验心灵，而不仅仅是分析它。
His new psychology never really came together coherently, and he never found the technique to validate his instinct. Hellman had been out of the Jungian fold for almost 30 years before he returned as a self-appointed expert advisor during the publication of the Red Book. Hellman's interest in the Red Book was enough to make him swallow his pride in many previous statements to join the Jungians once again. It is likely that the archetypal psychology he was trying to create is what the Red Book itself is describing. Sanu Shamdasani is not a psychologist but a scholar of the history of psychology.
他的新心理学从未真正连贯地整合在一起，他也从未找到验证其直觉的技术。希尔曼在回归并担任《红书》出版期间的自封专家顾问之前，已经脱离荣格派近30年了。希尔曼对《红书》的兴趣足以让他放下自尊，收回之前的许多言论，再次加入荣格派的行列。很可能他试图创造的原型心理学正是《红书》本身所描述的内容。索努·沙姆达萨尼不是心理学家，而是心理学史学者。
His insights have the detachment of the theoretical, where Hillman's are more felt and more intuitive, but also more personal. One gets a sense during their discussion in the book that Hillman is marveling painfully at an experience that he had been hungry for for a long time. The Red Book seems to help him clarify the disorganized blueprints of his stillborn psychological model. While there is a pain in Hillman's words, there is also a peace that was rare to hear from such a flamboyant and unsettled psychologist. Sanu Shamdasani is the perfect living dialogue partner for Hillman to have in these talks that make up Lament. Shamdasani has one of the best BS detectors of maybe any Jungian,
他的见解具有理论上的超脱感，而希尔曼的见解则更具感性、更直观，但也更个人化。在阅读他们的讨论时，人们会感觉到希尔曼正在痛苦地惊叹于一种他渴望已久的体验。《红书》似乎帮助他理清了他那胎死腹中的心理学模型的杂乱蓝图。虽然希尔曼的言语中透着痛苦，但也有一种从这样一位浮夸且不安的心理学家口中难得听到的平静。索努·沙姆达萨尼是希尔曼在构成《哀歌》的这些谈话中完美的现实对话伙伴。沙姆达萨尼拥有可能是所有荣格派中最敏锐的“胡扯探测器”，
save David Tacey. Shamdasani has definitely avoided the fads, misappropriations, and superficialization that have plagued the Jungian school for decades. As editor of the Red Book, he knows more about the history and assembly of the text than any person save for Jung. Not only is he also one of the foremost living experts on Jung, but as a scholar he does not threaten the famously egotistical Hillman as a competing interpreting psychologist. The skin that Shamsudani has in this game is as an academic, while Hillman gets to play the prophet and the hero of the new psychology that they describe without threat or competition. Presumably, these talks were recorded as research
除了大卫·泰西（David Tacey）之外。沙姆达萨尼确实避免了困扰荣格学派几十年的时尚、挪用和肤浅化。作为《红书》的编辑，除了荣格本人，他比任何人都更了解该文本的历史和汇编过程。他不仅是当今最重要的荣格专家之一，而且作为学者，他不会像竞争性的解释心理学家那样威胁到以自我为中心的希尔曼。沙姆达萨尼在这场博弈中的身份是学者，而希尔曼则可以扮演他们所描述的新心理学的先知和英雄，无需面对威胁或竞争。据推测，这些谈话是作为
for a collaborative book to be co-authored by the two friends, and The Death of Hillman in 2011 made the publication as a dialogue in 2013 a necessity. If that is not the case, then the format of a dialogue makes little sense. If that is the case, it gives the book itself an almost mystical quality and elevates the conversation more to the spirit of a philosophical dialogue. We are only able to hear these men talk to each other and not to us. There is a deep reverberation between the resonant implications these men are seeing the Red Book have for modern psychology. However, they do not explain their insights to the reader, and their understanding can only be glimpsed intuitively. Like the briefcase in the movie Pulp Fiction, the audience sees the object only through its indirect effect on the character. We see the foggy outlines of
两位朋友合著书籍的研究资料而录制的，而希尔曼2011年的去世使得2013年以对话形式出版成为必然。如果事实并非如此，那么对话的形式就毫无意义。如果事实确实如此，它赋予了这本书一种近乎神秘的特质，并将对话提升到了哲学对话的精神高度。我们只能听到这些人彼此交谈，而不是对我们交谈。这些人所看到的《红书》对现代心理学的深远影响之间存在着深刻的共鸣。然而，他们并没有向读者解释他们的见解，他们的理解只能通过直觉窥见。就像电影《低俗小说》中的公文包一样，观众只能通过它对角色产生的间接影响来看到这个物体。我们看到了
the ethics that these men hope will guide modern psychology, but we are not quite able to see it as they see it. We have only an approximation through the context of their lives and their interpretation of Jung's private diary. This enriches a text that is ultimately about the limitations of understanding, because the limitation of this dialogue enriches the theme. One of the biggest criticisms of Lament when it was published was that the terms that the speakers used are never defined and thus the book's thesis is never objectivized or clarified. And while this is true if you're an English professor, the mystic and the therapist in me see the limitations as the book's strengths. The
这些男人希望引导现代心理学的伦理的模糊轮廓，但我们无法完全像他们那样看到它。我们只能通过他们生活的背景和他们对荣格私人日记的解读来获得近似的理解。这丰富了一部最终关于理解局限性的文本，因为这种对话的局限性丰富了主题。《哀歌》出版时最大的批评之一是，演讲者使用的术语从未被定义，因此该书的论点从未被客观化或澄清。虽然如果你是一位英语教授，这确实是真的，但作为神秘主义者和治疗师，我将这些局限性视为该书的优点。这种
philosophical dialectic turns the conversation into an extended metaphor that indirectly supports the themes of the text. The medium enriches the message. Much like a Socratic dialogue or a film script, the authors act more as characters and archetypes than essayists. The prophet and the scholar describe their function and the limitations as gatekeepers of the spiritual experience of each of their roles. Reading Lament, much like reading the Red Book, one gets the sense that one is witnessing a private but important moment in time. It is a moment that is not our moment and is only partially comprehensible to anyone but the author.
哲学辩证法将对话变成了一个间接支持文本主题的扩展隐喻。媒介丰富了信息。就像苏格拉底式的对话或电影剧本一样，作者更多地扮演角色和原型，而不是散文家。先知和学者描述了他们作为各自角色精神体验守门人的功能和局限性。阅读《哀歌》，就像阅读《红书》一样，人们会感觉到自己正在见证一个私人但重要的时刻。这是一个不属于我们的时刻，除了作者本人，任何人都只能部分理解。
Normally, that would be a weakness, but here it becomes a strength. Where normally the reader feels that a book is for them, here we feel that we are eavesdropping through a keyhole or from a phone line downstairs. The effect is superficially frustrating, but it also gives Lament a subtle quality to its spirituality that the Red Book lacks. Many of the obvious elements for discussion that one would assume would be in a conversation about the enormous Red Book are completely ignored in the dialogue. Hellman and Shamdasani's main takeaway is that the Red Book is about the dead. What they mean by the dead is never explained directly, and this was a major sticking point for other reviewers, but I think that their point works better undefined. They talk about the dead as a numinous term.
通常，这会是一个弱点，但在这里它变成了一个优点。通常读者会觉得一本书是为他们写的，而在这里，我们感觉自己是在通过钥匙孔或楼下的电话线偷听。这种效果在表面上令人沮丧，但它也赋予了《哀歌》一种《红书》所缺乏的微妙灵性。人们认为在关于宏大的《红书》的对话中应该讨论的许多明显元素，在对话中完全被忽略了。希尔曼和沙姆达萨尼的主要结论是，《红书》是关于“死者”的。他们所说的“死者”从未被直接解释，这是其他评论家的一大症结，但我认为他们的观点在未定义的情况下效果更好。他们将死者视为一个神圣的术语。
Perhaps they are speaking about the reality of death itself. Perhaps about the dead of history. Perhaps they are describing the impenetrable veil that we all see others enter but never see past ourselves. Maybe the concept contains all of these elements. Hellman, who was 82 at the time of having the conversation in Lament, may have been using the Red Book and his dialogue with Shamdasani to come to terms with his feelings about his own impending death. Perhaps it is undefined because these men are feeling something, or intuitively seeing
也许他们谈论的是死亡本身的现实。也许是关于历史的死者。也许他们描述的是我们都看着别人进入，但自己却从未看透的不可逾越的面纱。也许这个概念包含了所有这些元素。希尔曼在进行《哀歌》对话时已经82岁了，他可能一直在利用《红书》和他与沙姆达萨尼的对话来与自己对即将到来的死亡的感受达成和解。也许它之所以未被定义，是因为这些人正在感受某种东西，或者直觉地看到了
something that the living lack the intellectual language for. It is not that the authors do not know what they are talking about, they know, but they are not completely able to say it. Hellman was such an infuriatingly intuitive person and writer that his biggest downfall in his other books is that he often felt truths that he could not articulate, and instead he would retreat into arguing the merits of his credentials and background, or into intellectual archival of his opinions on philosophers and artists and history. And in his other works, this led to a didactic and self-righteous tone that his writing is largely worse for. In Lament, Hillman is forced to talk off the cuff, and that limitation puts
某种活人缺乏智力语言来表达的东西。并不是作者不知道他们在谈论什么，他们知道，但他们无法完全说出来。希尔曼是一位令人恼火的直觉型人物和作家，他在其他著作中最大的失败在于，他经常感受到无法表达的真理，于是他会退缩到争论自己的资历和背景的优点，或者退缩到对他对哲学家、艺术家和历史的观点的知识性归档中。在他的其他作品中，这导致了一种说教和自以为是的语调，使他的写作大打折扣。在《哀歌》中，希尔曼被迫即兴发言，这种局限性使
him at his best as a thinker. In his review of Lament, David Tacey has made the very good point that Jung abandoned the direction that the Red Book was taking him in. Jung saw it as a dead end for the experiential psychology and retreated back into analytical inventorying of archetypes. On the publication of the Red Book, many Jungians celebrated the book as the culmination of Jungian thought, when instead, as Tacey points out, it was merely part of its origins. The book represents a proto-Jungian psychology, as Jung attempted to discover techniques for integration while he was directly experiencing the things that he was directly experiencing when he that he was directly experiencing when
他作为思想家达到了最佳状态。大卫·泰西在对《哀歌》的评论中提出了一个非常好的观点，即荣格放弃了《红书》所引领的方向。荣格将其视为体验心理学的死胡同，并退回到了对原型的分析性盘点中。在《红书》出版时，许多荣格派人士将其庆祝为荣格思想的巅峰，而正如泰西所指出的，它实际上只是其起源的一部分。这本书代表了一种原始的荣格心理学，因为荣格在撰写《红书》时，正试图在直接体验这些事物的同时，寻找整合的技术。
he wrote the Red Book. Hellman and Shamdasani probed the psychology's origins for hints of its future in lament. Hellman and Shamdasani's thesis is partially a question about ethics and partially a question about cosmology. Are there any universal directions for living and behaving that Jungian psychology compels us towards? That would be ethics. Is there an external worldview that the notoriously phenomenological nature of Jungian psychology might imply? That would be a cosmology. These are the major questions that Hillman and Shambhasani confront and lament.
希尔曼和沙姆达萨尼在《哀歌》中探究了该心理学的起源，以寻找其未来的线索。希尔曼和沙姆达萨尼的论点部分是关于伦理的问题，部分是关于宇宙论的问题。荣格心理学是否迫使我们走向任何普遍的生活和行为方向？那是伦理学。荣格心理学那著名的现象学本质是否暗示了一种外部的世界观？那是宇宙论。这些是希尔曼和沙姆达萨尼在《哀歌》中面对的主要问题。
Their answer is not an answer as much as it is a question for the psychologists of the future. Their conclusion is that the dead of our families, society, and human history foist their unlived lives upon us. It is up to us and our therapists to help deal with the burden of the dead. It is not us that live, but the dead that live through us. And Hillman quotes W.H. Auden several times to serve his point. The quote that he prefers is, we are lived through powers that we pretend to understand. This was definitely true of Hillman if you've read his other work. A major tenant of Jungian psychology is that adult children struggle under the unlived life of the
他们的回答与其说是一个答案，不如说是给未来心理学家提出的一个问题。他们的结论是，我们家庭、社会和人类历史的死者将他们未竟的生活强加于我们。处理死者的负担取决于我们和我们的治疗师。不是我们在生活，而是死者通过我们生活。希尔曼多次引用W.H.奥登的话来支持他的观点。他最喜欢的引文是：“我们被我们假装理解的力量所驱动。”如果你读过希尔曼的其他作品，这对他来说绝对是真实的。荣格心理学的一个主要原则是，成年子女在父母未竟的生活下挣扎。
parent. The Jungian analyst helps the patient acknowledge and integrate all the forces of the psyche that the parent ran from and so they are not passed down to future generations. A passive implication of the ethics and the cosmology laid out in Lament is that to have a future we must reckon with not only the unlived life of the parent, but also the unlived life of the dead, our civilization, our history, and our humanity, and the people who have failed at the projects that we are picking up. It is our job as the living to answer the questions and face the contradictions that our humanity posits in order answer the questions and face the contradictions that our humanity posits in order to discover who and what we really are.
荣格分析师帮助病人承认并整合父母逃避的所有心灵力量，这样它们就不会传给后代。《哀歌》中提出的伦理和宇宙论的一个被动含义是，为了拥有未来，我们不仅必须面对父母未竟的生活，还必须面对死者、我们的文明、我们的历史、我们的人性，以及那些在我们正在接手的项目中失败的人们。作为生者，我们的工作是回答问题并面对我们人性所提出的矛盾，以便发现我们到底是谁、是什么。
The half-truths and outright lies from the past masquerade as tradition for tradition's sake, literalized religion, and unconscious tribal identity, but that must be overthrown. The weight of the debt of history can remain immovable if we try to merely discard it, but it drowns us if we cling to it too tightly. We need to use our history and our tradition to give us a container to reckon with the future. The container must remain flexible if we are to grow into our humanity as a society and an aware people. If you find yourself saying, yes, but what does the dead mean? Then this book is probably not for you.
来自过去的半真半假和彻头彻尾的谎言，伪装成传统、字面化的宗教和无意识的部落认同，但这些必须被推翻。如果我们试图仅仅丢弃历史债务的重量，它可能会纹丝不动，但如果我们抓得太紧，它就会淹没我们。我们需要利用我们的历史和传统来为我们提供一个容器，以应对未来。如果我们作为一个社会和一个有意识的民族要成长为我们的人性，这个容器必须保持灵活。如果你发现自己在说：“是的，但‘死者’是什么意思？”那么这本书可能不适合你。
If you find yourself confused by this review, but humbled by this thesis, then perhaps this book is for you. Instead of a further explanation of the ethical and cosmological future for psychology that this book posits, I'll give you a tangible example about how its message was liberatory for me. Oddly enough, the idea of a descent and return will already be familiar to many Americans through the work of Joseph Campbell. Campbell took the same ethics of descent and return to the unconscious as the model for his monomyth model of storytelling. This briefly influenced psychology and comparative religion in the U.S. and had a major impact on screenwriters to this day. Most of Campbell's influence on psychology is contained to the 1970s and 80s.
如果你对这篇书评感到困惑，但对这个论点感到谦卑，那么这本书可能适合你。与其进一步解释这本书所提出的心理学的伦理和宇宙论未来，我将给你一个具体的例子，说明它的信息对我来说是如何具有解放意义的。奇怪的是，通过约瑟夫·坎贝尔的作品，许多美国人已经熟悉了“下降与回归”的概念。坎贝尔采用了同样的下降到无意识并回归的伦理，作为他叙事“英雄之旅”模型的模型。这在短期内影响了美国的心理学和比较宗教学，并对至今的编剧产生了重大影响。坎贝尔对心理学的大部分影响仅限于20世纪70年代和80年代。
Campbell's ethics are the same as Jung's, though. If one becomes stuck on the monomyth wheel, or the journey to the unconscious and then the return to the integrated conscious, then one is no longer the protagonist and one becomes the antagonist. Campbell and American post-Jungians in general were not always great about attributing influences and credit where it was due, and Campbell did not do a great job of pointing out that the tradition he was describing was coming from Jung's psychology. Jung was suspicious of the new age theosophists and psychedelic psychonauts that became enamored with the structure of the unconscious for the unconscious sake during the new age movement and the interest in psychedelic drugs and mystical experimentation. Where lament shines
然而，坎贝尔的伦理与荣格的相同。如果一个人被困在英雄之旅的轮子上，或者被困在通往无意识的旅程以及随后回归整合意识的过程中，那么他就不再是主角，而变成了反派。坎贝尔和美国后荣格派总体上并不总是善于归功于影响和来源，坎贝尔也没有很好地指出他所描述的传统来自荣格的心理学。荣格对新时代神智学家和迷幻心理探索者持怀疑态度，这些人在新时代运动和对迷幻药物及神秘实验的兴趣中，迷恋于无意识的结构本身。《哀歌》的闪光点
is when Hillman explains the ethics behind Jung's thinking here. Jung lightly implied this ethics, but was, as Hillman points out, probably not entirely conscious of it. One of lament's biggest strengths and weaknesses is that it sees through the misappropriations of Jungian psychology over the last hundred years. Both of the dialogue figures know the man of Jung so well that they do not need to address how he was misperceived by the public, and they also know the limitations of the knowable. This is another lesson that is discussed in lament. Can modern psychology know what it can't know? That is my biggest complaint with the profession as it currently exists. Modern psychology seems content to retreat into research and objectivism. The medical, corporate, and credentialist academic structure
在于希尔曼解释了荣格在此处的思想背后的伦理。荣格轻描淡写地暗示了这种伦理，但正如希尔曼所指出的，他可能并没有完全意识到这一点。《哀歌》最大的优点和缺点之一是，它看穿了过去一百年来对荣格心理学的挪用。对话中的两位人物对荣格本人非常了解，以至于他们不需要讨论他如何被公众误解，他们也知道可知事物的局限性。这是《哀歌》中讨论的另一个教训。现代心理学能知道它所不能知道的东西吗？这是我目前对这个职业最大的抱怨。现代心理学似乎满足于退回到研究和客观主义中。20世纪80年代心理学的医疗、企业和证书学术结构
of psychology in the 1980s certainly furthered that problem. Jung did not believe that the descent into the unconscious without any hope of return was a path forward for psychology. This is why he abandoned the path that the Red Book was leading him down. Can psychology let go of the objective and the researchable enough to embrace the limits of the knowable? Can we come to terms with limitation enough to heal an ego-inflated world that sees no limits to growth? I don't know, but I sincerely hope so. I said that I would provide a tangible example of the application of this book and its review, so here it is. I have always been enamored with James Hillman.
无疑加剧了这个问题。荣格并不认为没有回归希望的无意识下降是心理学的前进道路。这就是为什么他放弃了《红书》引领他的道路。心理学能否放下客观和可研究的东西，去拥抱可知事物的局限性？我们能否与局限性达成和解，从而治愈一个看不到增长极限、自我膨胀的世界？我不知道，但我衷心希望如此。我说过我会提供一个应用这本书及其书评的具体例子，所以这就是了。我一直很迷恋詹姆斯·希尔曼。
He was by all accounts a brilliant analyst. He was an incredibly intelligent person. And that intellect did not save him. Hillman ended his career as kind of a crank and a failure in my mind. In this book, you see Hillman contemplate that failure. You also see Hillman attempt to redeem himself as he glimpses the unglimpsable. He sees something in the Red Book that he allows to clarify his early attempt to revision psychology. Hellman's attempt to reinvent Jungian psychology as archetypal psychology was wildly derided, largely because it never found any language or technique for application and practice. Hellman himself admitted that he did not know how to practice archetypal psychology.
据各方评价，他是一位出色的分析师。他是一个极其聪明的人。而那种智慧并没有拯救他。在我看来，希尔曼以一种怪人和失败者的身份结束了他的职业生涯。在这本书中，你看到希尔曼思考那种失败。你还看到希尔曼试图通过窥见不可窥见之物来救赎自己。他在《红书》中看到了一些东西，他允许这些东西来澄清他早期重构心理学的尝试。希尔曼试图将荣格心理学重塑为原型心理学的尝试遭到了猛烈的嘲笑，主要是因为它从未找到任何应用和实践的语言或技术。希尔曼本人承认他不知道如何实践原型心理学。
It's easy to laugh at somebody who claims that they have reinvented psychology and they can't even tell you what to do with their revolutionary invention. However, I will admit that I think Hillman was right. He knew that he was right, but he did not know how he was right. It is a mark of arrogance to see yourself as correct without evidence, and Hillman was often arrogant, but I think here he was not. Many Jungian analysts would leave the Jungian institutes through the 70s, 80s, and 90s to start somatic and experiential psychology that used Jung as a map, but the connection between the body and the brain as a technique for direct experience. These models made room for a direct experience in psychology that Jungian analysis does not often do.
嘲笑一个声称自己重塑了心理学却甚至不能告诉你如何使用其革命性发明的人是很容易的。然而，我承认我认为希尔曼是对的。他知道他是对的，但他不知道他是如何对的。在没有证据的情况下认为自己正确是一种傲慢的表现，希尔曼经常很傲慢，但我认为在这里他不是。许多荣格分析师在70、80和90年代离开荣格研究所，开始使用荣格作为地图的躯体和体验心理学，但将身体和大脑之间的联系作为直接体验的技术。这些模型为心理学中的直接体验留出了空间，而荣格分析通常不会这样做。
And it added an element that Jung himself had practiced when he wrote the Red Book. Hillman never found this technique, but he was correct about the path that he saw forward for psychology. He knew what was missing. I started Taproot Therapy Collective because I felt a calling to dig up the Jungian techniques of my parents' generation and reify them. And I also saw those as the most viable map towards the future of psychology, even though American psychology had largely forgotten those techniques. I also saw them devoid of practical technique or application for a world where years of analysis cost more than most trauma patients will make in a lifetime. I feel that the experiential and brain-based medicine techniques like brain spotting are the future of the profession.
它增加了一个荣格本人在撰写《红书》时实践过的元素。希尔曼从未找到这种技术，但他对他所看到的心理学前进道路是正确的。他知道缺少什么。我创办“主根疗法集体”是因为我感到一种召唤，去挖掘我父母那一代的荣格技术并将其具体化。我也认为这些是通往心理学未来最可行的地图，尽管美国心理学在很大程度上已经忘记了这些技术。我也看到它们缺乏针对一个分析费用比大多数创伤患者一生收入还高的世界的实用技术或应用。我觉得像“大脑定位”（Brainspotting）这样的体验式和基于大脑的医学技术是该行业的未来。
Pathways like brain spotting, sensory motor therapy, somatic experiencing, neurostimulation, ketamine, psilocybin, or any other technique that allows for direct experience of the subcortical brain is the path forward to treat trauma. These things will be at odds with the medicalized, corporate, and credentialized nature of healthcare. I knew that this would be poorly understood as a path that few people, even the well-intentioned, would be able to see, but I never would have found it if I had refused the call of the dead that is being talked about in this book. Lament is relevant because none of those realizations is somewhere that I ever would have gotten without the tradition that I am standing on top of. I am, as Isaac Newton said,
像大脑定位、感觉运动疗法、躯体体验、神经刺激、氯胺酮、裸盖菇素或任何其他允许直接体验皮层下大脑的技术，都是治疗创伤的前进道路。这些东西将与医疗化、企业化和证书化的医疗保健性质相冲突。我知道这会被误解为一条很少有人（即使是善意的人）能看到的道路，但如果我拒绝了这本书中所谈论的死者的召唤，我就永远不会找到它。《哀歌》之所以相关，是因为如果没有我所立足的传统，我永远不会得到这些领悟。正如艾萨克·牛顿所说，我
standing on the shoulders of giants, except Isaac Newton didn't invent that phrase. It was associated with him, but he was standing on the tradition of the dead to utter a phrase that was first recorded in the medieval period. We don't remember the person who first said that. The author of its origin is unknown because they are, well, dead, and they have no one to give their eulogy. The ethics and cosmology of lament is that our lives are meant to be a eulogy for our dead. Lament makes every honest eulogy in history become an ethics, and by extension, a cosmology. Read Pericles' eulogy from the Peloponnesian War in Thucydides. How many of these lessons are still unlearned? I would feel disingenuous in my career unless I tell you who these giants are that I stand on.
站在巨人的肩膀上，尽管艾萨克·牛顿并没有发明这个短语。它与他有关，但他站在死者的传统之上，说出了一个最早记录在中世纪的短语。我们不记得第一个说出这句话的人。它的起源作者不详，因为他们，嗯，死了，没有人为他们写悼词。《哀歌》的伦理和宇宙论是，我们的生活注定要成为我们死者的悼词。《哀歌》使历史上每一篇诚实的悼词都成为一种伦理，进而成为一种宇宙论。读读修昔底德《伯罗奔尼撒战争史》中伯里克利的悼词。有多少教训至今仍未被吸取？除非我告诉你我所站立的这些巨人是谁，否则我在我的职业生涯中会感到虚伪。
They are David Tacey, they are John Beebe, they are Carl Jung, they are Sanu Shandasani, they are Fritz Perls, they are Karen Horney, they are Hal Stone, and many, many others. They are all of the people that I use to have the perspective that I have now that I never could have built on my own. I would never have heard the voices of James Hillman inside myself unless I had learned to listen to the dead from his voice beyond the grave, and it would have been easy for me to merely criticize his failures instead of seeing him as incomplete truths. Hillman died with many things incomplete, as we all inevitably will, and Lament helped me clarify the voices that I was hearing in the profession. Lament of the dead is a fascinating read, not because it tells us exactly what to do with the dead or even what they are.
他们是大卫·泰西、约翰·比比（John Beebe）、卡尔·荣格、索努·沙姆达萨尼、弗里茨·皮尔斯（Fritz Perls）、卡伦·霍妮（Karen Horney）、哈尔·斯通（Hal Stone）以及许多许多其他人。他们都是我用来获得我现在所拥有的视角的人，而这些视角我永远无法独自建立。除非我学会了从他超越坟墓的声音中倾听死者，否则我永远不会听到詹姆斯·希尔曼在我内心的声音，而我很容易仅仅批评他的失败，而不是将他视为不完整的真理。希尔曼带着许多未完成的事情去世了，正如我们所有人最终都会那样，而《哀歌》帮助我理清了我在这个行业中听到的声音。《死者的哀歌》是一本引人入胜的读物，不是因为它告诉我们确切地该如何对待死者，甚至不是告诉我们他们是什么。
Lament is fascinating because it helps us to see a mindful path forward between innovation and tradition. The contents of the collective unconscious cannot be contained by one individual. Just as Jungian psychology is meant to be a container to help an individual integrate the forces of the collective unconscious, attention to the unlived life of the historical dead can be a kind of container for our culture. Similarly to Jungian psychology, the container is not meant to be literalized or turned into a prison. It is a lens and a buffer to protect us until we are ready and allow us to see ourselves more clearly once we are. Our project is to go further into the journey of knowing ourselves where our ancestors failed to. Our mindful life is the product of the unlived life
《哀歌》之所以引人入胜，是因为它帮助我们在创新与传统之间看到了一条理性的前进道路。集体无意识的内容不能被一个人所容纳。正如荣格心理学旨在成为一个容器，帮助个人整合集体无意识的力量一样，关注历史死者未竟的生活也可以成为我们文化的一种容器。与荣格心理学类似，这个容器不应被字面化或变成监狱。它是一个透镜和缓冲器，保护我们直到我们准备好，并允许我们在准备好后更清晰地看到自己。我们的项目是深入到我们祖先失败的地方，去探索认识我们自己的旅程。我们理性的生活是死者
of the dead. It is the work of our life that is their lament, and their unlived life is our work to be done. Thank you so much for listening, and I hope that was interesting. If you have interest, you can order Lament of the Dead from Amazon or from anywhere else where you get your books. And if you have a question or a comment, please get in touch. Send me an email at joelblackstock at gettherapybirmingham.com or check out the website gettherapybirmingham.com. Thank you and have a nice night. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
未竟生活的产物。我们生活的工作就是他们的哀歌，而他们未竟的生活就是我们要完成的工作。非常感谢您的收听，希望这很有趣。如果您有兴趣，可以从亚马逊或任何其他购买书籍的地方订购《死者的哀歌》。如果您有任何问题或评论，请与我联系。给我发电子邮件至 joelblackstock@gettherapybirmingham.com 或访问网站 gettherapybirmingham.com。谢谢，祝您晚安。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。